Speaker 1: We have major news in terms of the more
than 700 cases against the alleged Trump rioters,
there's more than 700 total cases. Now, in one
of the things we've been wondering waiting for
is thinking about is will there be more serious
charges? A lot of the charges, even though
collectively this was an attempted insurrection,
this coup to install the guy who lost in the White
House, that was the general point of it. To really
charge people with anything even remotely close to
that requires pretty. You've got a close to have
these people dead to rights and really be able to
prove what they intended in participating in those
riots. And that's really tough. We've talked about
perjury. People perjure themselves all the time
in court, using the term perjury colloquially. But
proving perjury is quite difficult and you really
don't see even a small fraction of instances of
perjury actually prosecuted. A lot of the stuff
we're talking about with January 6th, including
sedition, is quite difficult to prove, and thus
it makes it. It makes it tough to say we're going
to charge people with that. That has now changed
and things are changing very, very dramatically.
The leader of the Oath Keepers and ten other
individuals have been indicted in federal court
for seditious conspiracy and other offenses
related to the U.S. Capitol breach. This is
sort of a crossing of the Rubicon when it comes
to the Jan. six riots, and the Justice Department
publication says that a federal grand jury in D.C.
returned an indictment charging 11 defendants with
seditious conspiracy. One of the main charges here
is a guy named Elmer Stewart Rhodes, the third,
a 56 year old Texan who is the founder and leader
of the Oath Keepers. That's a right wing militia
type group. Rhodes was arrested in Texas. Another
another guy, Edward Viejo, 63, also charged
with seditious conspiracy. A bunch of other
previously named defendants have been charged.
Eight other individuals affiliated with the Oath
Keepers have been charged in the investigation,
and they remain as defendants in two related
cases. These are really, really serious
charges. The seditious conspiracy indictment
alleges that following the 2020 election,
Rhodes conspired with co-defendants to oppose
by force the execution of the laws governing the
transfer of presidential power by January 20th.
They, via encrypted and private communications,
coordinated and planned to travel to D.C.
around January 6th. To bring weapons to
support their operation. They did travel and they
conspired through a variety of manners in means,
including organizing into teams prepared to use
force to transport firearms and ammunition. They
recruited people. They organized trainings to
teach and learn paramilitary combat tactics
on and on and on with the point of preventing
the lawful transfer of presidential power.
These are really, really serious charges and
a sort of I don't know that we would call this
funny. But one of the things that the right has
been saying, and Tucker has been saying this and
other Fox News host and others saying if this was
an insurrection coup, if they were doing sedition,
why haven't they been charged with that?
In fact, just hours before the charges?
Fox News dude Brit Hume, although to be honest,
I don't even know if he's still at Fox News,
but Brit Hume, who for a long time was that
he is still a political analyst on Fox News.
He tweeted, Here's a thought let's base our view
on whether one six was an insurrection on whether
those arrested are charged with insurrection.
So far, none has been within hours charges
for seditious conspiracy to prevent a peaceful
transfer of power. I had tweeted, So I guess
they were waiting on the more serious charges.
And a CNN legal analyst, Asuran GOPer, said I
don't think they were waiting. The more serious
charges are also more complex and can take longer
to gather evidence and put together. If you look
at the indictment, it is incredibly detailed and
you can't get that information overnight. So as
Vox has now reported, these charges really change
the whole feel of the riots. Vox writing Seditious
conspiracy occurs when two or more people work
together to plan to overthrow the government
or the X, or prevent the execution of its laws,
and that now on the basis of these
charges. This has really stepped things up
before we had seen disorderly conduct, obstructing
an official proceeding before Congress.
And even there, we've seen sentences close
to four years. Seditious conspiracy carries
a potential sentence of 20 years in prison. And
importantly, these new charges refute the argument
that the entire riots were overblown. That's
been a story we hear from many right wingers.
This is all overblown. It wasn't an attempted
coup, was it an attempted insurrection and
nobody's been charged with anything like that.
Well, now they have, and we may see we may see
instead of form one month sentences. We could
see 10 12, potentially up to 20, but probably not
year sentences. And that completely changes the
entire story about what happened on Jan. six.
Could there be even more serious charges? Maybe.
Maybe we're going to wait and see. Let me know
your thoughts. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman and tell me what you think
about this. Our program is an audience funded
program, and I would love for you to sign
up at join Packman dot com, we do an extra show
every day for our members. You can use the coupon
code wwr to to get a sizable discount and instant
access to all of these great membership perks